[Music]
normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we got
this one from the Boston heral ladies
and gentlemen Biden says he wouldn't be
seeking reelection if Trump wasn't
running which is the weirdest headline
because if it's anyone other than Joe
Biden Trump loses according to numerous
polls so let me break this down Biden
claims he's at here's a quote if Trump
wasn't running I'm not sure I'd be
running but we can't let him win Biden
said at a fundraiser at a private event
near near Boston according to a pool
report Biden just celebrated his 81st
birthday he went on to warn that Trump
has made clear what his plans would be
if he wins Trump's not even hiding the
ball anymore he's telling us what he's
going to do he's making no bones about
it Biden saided Trump's comments he's
out for Retribution if he wins Biden is
just really trying to get me to vote for
for Donald Trump here but let's slow
this down Biden claiming that he
wouldn't be seeking re-election if Trump
wasn't running that's the headline
that's the story if Biden didn't run
there's a poll from NBC showing that any
other Democratic candidate is 46 to
Trump's 40% but with Biden it's like
Trump 43 to like Biden 39 which is to
say Joe Biden just admitted he's a trump
supporter and he wants Trump trump to
win and that's his true intention I'm
loving this this is hilarious so Biden
wants retribution too yeah and he's like
you know come on man you know if Trump's
going to win I got to be here if I leave
he'll lose I guess
I love it I I just think it's so lame
right like you want a president that has
a vision for what he wants to accomplish
in the in the country right and and he's
saying he's just running to stop Trump
like you you need an altruistic
president with a vision I mean we
obviously know he doesn't have that
that's not a surprise to us but it's
lame that he's actually admitting it I
fully agree we want somebody with a
vision that's like one of my number one
on my bucket list of Tod do for a
president is give me something to live
for what's the next 20 years going to
look like bro I want I want a president
that has a vision about like not doing
stuff all these presidents that like do
things like I I want a president that
wants to do less I we have the the
largest government in human history well
to to clarify my argument if he's like
I'm going to shut down this organization
and this organ Vision a plan okay okay
I'd be open to that but I I want some
long-term like how you are my kids going
to be okay in 20 years and why you you
want the most powerful job on Earth you
better get a reason I think one of the
things that's actually helping Democrats
is they don't need to campaign on kids
cuz liberals don't have kids so it's
it's really simple they they they they
target the you those you those viral
videos about dinks I was just going to
say do you think that like the dink
stuff is is that's
D no kids what does dink double income
no kids and so uh Biden is basically I'm
going to forgive your student loan debt
why so you can go party come on baby I
just got an email was I telling you guys
about that I was telling Luke about it
while I was down there on we chain show
best political show.com and that I got
an email like last week hey by the way
we you have no more debt I just saw all
of my student debt I thought it was like
8,000 of the 19,000 was gone it was all
of it it's all gone and then it went
180,000 more people got that same email
so wait how much how much did they
forgive uh for me total 19 thou I paid
off 6800 is that income I don't know IRS
might call so people like hey that might
be considered income I'm like well I
didn't get it it just disappeared I
didn't so I got I'll find out next year
if an income they forced repayment early
when when when Oprah Winfrey gave
everybody those cars they're like no
that's
income and and and there was a a now
that's a little different you're giving
a car you're giving value but there was
also uh occupy did this thing where they
were paying off medical debt so what you
what they would do is they would contact
the uh uh the hospitals and say this
person's been delinquent how long okay
we'll pay off their debt for 10% and so
someone would owe 10 grand and then they
would pay $1,000 and wipe their debt or
even or even less pennies but people
were then pointing out hey they have to
report that as income because you paid
their debt off what's so dirty about
this is if they took I had like say
$10,000 left to pay off that's my and if
they force me to pay that back early and
then they're going to tax me on that
forced repayment that's like pure I mean
that's my debt you can't pay my debt
back without my consent that's insane
especially if you tax my friends to pay
for it right that would be the most epic
move by democrats is to like forgive
every all the debt but then tax everyone
on the forgive debt so now they all have
to pay more money and they have debt to
the government acceler yeah un
unsolicited accelerated repayments like
the but so it's like someone's got a
loan with a private you know or they're
they're all Federal loans I guess that
are being forgiven so yeah even if it's
if it's not taxed it's still insane that
if they've taxed my friends to pay for
it that's like Insidious there there's
there is no there's nothing that we've
discussed that is beyond what the
government has already done in like
historically done the government like
Japanese internment camp infinitely
worse than them taking people's money
for taxes yeah or or I mean whether
that's the the extreme that the the US
government has done it stuff like Jim
Crow or or or internment camps um when
it comes to actually like you know
monetary policy and your property and
stuff the government demanded that
everyone turn in any gold they had any
any gold they owned at
all no longer allowed to own it so that
kind of stuff government does those kind
of makes those kind of decrees and and
and stuff all the time and it's so we're
going to we're going to see uh this
student loan repayment is instant
inflation yeah instant because money
that wouldn't would not have been in
circulation is now instantly in
circulation and the argument is it'll
stimulate the economy sure and now it's
going to immediately result in in Rapid
inflation as more people are spending
more money very very rapidly it's uh
it's it's it's such a dirty move and I
you know one of the dirtiest things
about it I do do think we're facing a
self-correcting problem you know you got
these viral videos where it's like a man
and a woman and they'll film each other
I'm a dink I can go and do this because
I don't have kids and yeah I'm a dink I
can do this and it's these people are
excising themselves in the gene pool
they're not this these ideas will cease
to exist Democrats are utilizing that
short-term opportunity to win political
power and then try and maintain a system
which slowly just shuffles people off
into an an ideology that results in them
excising them from the gene pool I wish
excise the ideas but since they're
making internet video those stupid ideas
stay around for people like long after
those two dinks are gone that someone's
going to see the video be like they must
have had a great life I should be a dink
too I disagree you don't think I I
believe you're half correct the video
will process people can see it it may
influence some people but the reality is
people who are like imagine if a video
popped up and there was a a guy being
like I took a dump on my floor that
means I don't got to hire a plumber
you'd watch that you'd be like that's
the stupidest thing I ever heard I would
never do that that's right that's what
might happen with these videos if if the
Liberals aren't having kids and they're
aborting their kids and the the rate at
which they reproduce is dramatically
Lower Blue states allow abortions and
red states don't let's just make it very
very simple for everybody the the the
one reason conservatives should be
celebrating the the overturning of roie
Wade is not that it's made abortion
illegal in some places it's that it's
given them a guaranteed path to our long
path towards a long-term Victory because
blue State's populations will decline
they are there's already an exodus and
they're already not having kids and now
they have an opportunity to abort up to
the point of birth if you were to ask me
I would say that Democrat politicians
hate Democrat voters more than anyone
else I got kind of this mixed feeling I
was thinking earlier about this about
people that are changing their gender or
getting surgeries on their genitals so
that they can't have kids anymore or
they're just opting out like in a way
it's like you might think okay that's
that's fine and good because that means
they'll weed away and it's like maybe if
those people are mentally ill or if
they're just have some sort of illness
then we need less mental illness in the
system that's maybe that's okay but the
reality is I want less I I I agree like
less ill people is good but that doesn't
mean I don't want them to be sick in the
first place I want to find out what's
making these people this way and solve
that and fix it it's it's that they
don't have any family it's that they
don't have any kids right like I look I
know that's not making them sick no no
no but it's making them immature it's
yeah it's making them liberal so like
here's how I view it look I know I'm a
freak I got six kids with our seventh on
the way we like our kids we like our
family it's it's there's something
mysterious about it though in that it
forces you to grow up it forces you to
sacrifice like when you've got screaming
kids the next morning you're a lot less
likely to get trashed the night before
you got you got to make a video with
your wife where you're like I'm a parent
my kid mows a lawn for me I'm a parent I
don't got to do the dishes anymore we
put them to work now right like Saturday
morning so here's our system right it's
called dat days dat days we get up at 7
whatever time what you know they get up
6:30 7:00 sometimes but they got to
clean the house clean the living room
clean the dining room you know put
everything away and they do that they
get donuts get to go to the movies get
to go to dve Busters something fun that
day it's D day it's the day that they
get to spend with their dad it works out
really well because we get a clean home
the lawn gets stunn you're you're you're
not crazy Tim that's how it works with
big families that's how that's why the
families used to be bigger was cuz you'd
want to have more workers for your for
your farm or whatever business it was
and because they were like kids died a
lot at very very young ages babies and
and miscar and stuff so they're
constantly having kids and then they're
having a lot of them and then a kid
might die at four years old so it's just
like if you don't have kids you got to
keep doing it y but look man Democrats
continually uh offer up policies that
destroy Democrat positions look at their
policing policies they want to abolish
police in like the worst criminal areas
ever like there there I I'm I'm just
going to bring it back to without
getting into an abortion debate just the
the idea that someone would look at you
and be like I think you should have
bought your kid I like I I want to make
sure like if someone come to you and
said you know I want to make sure that
if at any point even the point of birth
your wife wants to terminate the
pregnancy I'm going to make sure she can
you're going to be like what are you
saying but but but but but go back to
the Dink videos right like the Dink
videos like if if my wife was telling me
that she didn't want to have any more
kids anymore with us or with me I would
be really insulted like you don't love
me enough to keep having kids I look
we're we're reaching the the the older
Agee and and the maximum limit of kids
we're going to be able to have but like
if we first got married and my wife was
unwilling to have kids with me it would
hurt really bad and and I think the same
thing on her end I think it would be
insulting so it's it's it's more than
abortion but I think that's a really
good point like it is so offensive to
tell someone that they should abort
their children or that they should be
like it's it's I don't think Democrats
are coming out being like abort your
kids but they're like you know I I want
to make sure that there is no
restriction on your wife's choice to
abort your children it's like you're
basically saying I hope you die like you
should not so that's what they're going
for and it's just like the end result of
this in the longest in the long run is
red states are restricting abortion blue
states are allowing it that's a pressure
system that flows in One Direction
people are going to leave Blue States
and and you know I hear people say yeah
but Tim immigration I'm like oh yeah
yeah it doesn't matter the illegal
immigrants that are coming in will still
have the same access to abortion which
plan parent are mostly in uh non-white
areas so like I'm sorry man like the
Democrats seem to really hate their
voter base but but but it it they create
more voters the more chaos and
destruction that they Cause right the
more that we stray from normaly and
goodness and Beauty the more everyone
just thinks life sucks the world sucks
uh I'm a miserable person miserable
people vote for Communists that like no
happy person votes for communism it's
just not how it works and so they want
to cause disorder they want to cause
unhappiness they don't want you having
kids because that gives you an
investment in the future it gives you
something to look forward to um it's
they benefit from the chaos and and the
dysfunction I just figured out the uh
student loan repayment thing so you got
people who aren't paying back their
student loans right that money is
basically a debt that's a dead debt bill
you know you go to you go to some guy
and you're like where's my money he's
like I don't got it you can't beat money
out of him it's not there so what do you
do well you can garnish wages but then
people are going to lose their minds I
got a plan now if someone owes you money
and you're not going to get the full
amount what do you do you negotiate a
lower okay what can you pay me so for
hospitals and credit cards they'll say
what this this is a trick a lot of
people need to understand if you owe
like a th000 bucks on your credit card
and you're not paying it and they're
mailing you and mailing you and mailing
you you can call them up and offer them
300 bucks and say you you cancel the
whole that I'll give you 300 bucks
otherwise you get nothing they'll say
yes not always but they'll say okay fine
send us 300 bucks we'll close it out
this is what Joe Biden's doing he's
looking at all these student student
loans and he's like you know we're not
getting any of this money back let's
forgive it all you know why the
Forgiveness qualifies as income and then
they don't get a tax refund at the end
of the year we get to keep all their
money so we're not getting back the full
student loan debt but if someone owns
owes us 10 grand and we pay them 10
grand that's 3K in taxes they owe us
then when it comes to refund season they
don't get a refund we keep the three
grand
so we're not they're not giving money
with student loan repayment they're just
saying you don't owe us anything anymore
but that counts his income now you got
to give me three grand yeah and and and
instantly comes out of your taxes
without you realizing it I'm wondering
if we're going to hear a lot of people
come you know like April you know just
being like whoa whoa whoa I didn't get a
refund this year yeah they took it
because but you know what's going to
happen is going to be like well my
student loans paid off so what do I care
but that that allows the government to
retain a large amount of money there
84,000 people got paid back 39 how much
was this 39 billion 39 billion what what
what's the average per person and then
slice off 35 or whatever 30% towards
taxes MH and uh that's how much they're
going to keep from the taxpayer without
giving back their refunds what is it
like like 4,000 granted not every
everyone's refund is that high it's only
up to like the the uh um what is it
what's what's the threshold for you
don't pay taxes like 15K or something uh
I don't something like that anyway
here's a story from axos just to to you
know to wrap up this portion of it it's
not just that Joe Biden said he was
going to uh he he wouldn't run if Trump
wasn't running even axos reported a
month ago Democrats have been working
behind the scenes a shadow campaign to
get rid of Joe Biden so we're about to
enter the New Year I hope yall are
excited for the holidays I know I am and
uh I I I just I don't
understand how they pull it off how do
they swap out Joe Biden is is this hint
that Donald Trump gets arrested or he's
already been arrested he gets he gets
convicted sentenced to prison and then
Joe Biden says look you know I said last
year if it weren't for Trump I wouldn't
be running now that he's convicted I
know he's running but this this he's
he's he's not here any he's not a threat
you's know I'm going to I'm going to bow
out and hand it off to somebody else
then the DNC declares Nome the or or
Gretchen Whitmer or something I just
threw up a little in my mouth when you
said that Whitmer she can't win so they
would never do Whitmer but some people
are they could do someone though like an
Andy Basher type you know out of
Kentucky yeah what do you think about
Nome I I'm not worried about Nome first
of all he looks like a he looks like the
dude from American Psycho right like he
looks like the joker now is this I I
want to push back I just want to make
sure I'm clear do you think that your
perspective
is is the is the Normie perspective or
do you think your P because the reason I
asked is I I was in California last week
and like my friends that are in LA and
stuff they generally don't look at Nome
and see the reptile that I see okay like
the
normies I think that someone like Nome
is
extremely
extremely appealing to normies and do
you think that your perspective is a
normie perspective or the perspective
that someone like us would have which is
that dude is definitely a reptile well I
think your biggest mistake is that
you're assuming people from California
are normies like they're the weirdest
people there are some I agree with Phil
new Nome is a master debater and that's
why it was a big mistake that Ronda
santis tried to go up against him
because there's no upside Nome isn't a
candidate so the only thing could happen
is negatives for for Ronda santis and
the important thing to understand about
Nome is that as a as a lizard person he
can literally say whatever he wants to
convince people so if he were to
campaign or debate he'll just say
literally nonsense he'll he'll he'll say
in the great state of California our GDP
is up
7.3% homelessness is down 88.9% don't
believe the lies and he just makes it up
and then what are you going to do about
it who's going to call him out not the
media of course there will be no fact TR
he can literally say whatever he wants
he can say that he he's with the he was
the the 15th guy to land on the moon and
that you know now he's here to bring his
expertise and oil to California so to so
go ahead with your point but but I I
really want to know if it's if you think
it's if it's if it's something that you
think is is a nonbiased
actual guess of what the normal person
is or something that you personally
prefer no so no no what I believe is
that the average normal human being has
no clue who Gavin Nome is for the most
part they have not been exposed to him
he can be branded and and and I think
I'm not I'm not desper you I'm not
depressed about Trump going after him
Trump has a way of branding people and I
think that we have to fight differently
though we can't count on the mainstream
media to hold them accountable this has
to be fought at the local coffee shops
at the breakfast bars that that's our
plan with casw we got to have these
local coffee shops where when you walk
in we got TVs playing it's going to be
timcast IRL it's going to be Crowder
it's going to be daily wire that's the
plan thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net